slip we've seen the biggest Fallen
living standards on record with people
on low or fixed incomes absolutely
terrified does the government understand
how scared people are what is the
message of support that's on its way
yeah very much so this is a difficult
time there are no easy options we see
Putin deliberately use energy as a tool
to get back at us for the help we're
putting into Ukraine and that is
obviously impacting families because of
energy costs impacting families because
of the cost of food as we saw today with
the inflation numbers we are working on
two things one is to deliver that 37
billion pound package we are Midway
through that so in a couple of months
time everyone will see 400 pounds off
their energy bills of course energy
bills are rising I recognize that those
who need additional help will see more
help through the household support fund
which we're extending until March of
next year working with local authorities
who know those families that need that
additional help and the other thing that
I'm doing that we're really focused on
is what more do we need to do for
January we prepare all the options ready
for the incoming prime minister on the
5th September to hit the ground running
of what more we can do whether it is the
green levees that we need to remove to
help with those energy bills cutting
taxes increasing our gas production here
at home and of course the one thing that
I'm beginning to really get concerned
about is the impact on small businesses
because of the energy Spike that they're
seeing which is obviously going to put a
huge pressure on smes 5.9 million small
businesses are the backbone of the
British economy the labor party says
it's going to freeze uh energy bills at
its current rate you're saying you're
not going to do anything extra until
January that is just too late people
understand freezing bills and largely
welcome it why do we have to wait so
long for your for your support well
we're not waiting we've got 37 billion
and we're part of the way through that
so 400 pounds in the next couple of
months off People's Energy bills for
everybody the 8 million people who need
that most urgent help are getting at
least 1200 pounds of additional direct
payments to them if you look at the
labor plans and look you know I'm happy
to look at any plans but when you start
to examine them there's a real problem
with them a couple of things one they
talk about paying for some of it because
inflation would come down what we see
today actually inflation took place
through on food costs and so their
numbers are out on this and they need to
work out and be honest with the nation
how they're going to pay for this the
other problem with it is actually you're
rewarding people like me who are you
know the wealthier end of the spectrum
and people who might have very high
energy uses and be wealthy is that the
right thing to do when you know money's
tight when we should be targeting it to
deliver that help and be resilient
against Putin is that really the right
thing to do to waste money on wealthier
households that have higher consumption
I don't think that's right with respect
to Kirsten so he needs to really sort of
explain uh why he thinks that right you
know it could be up to if this is
prolonged up to 90 billion of uh spend
when we've already obviously spent 408
billion on the covert response and we're
spending 37 billion now I would much
rather see targeted support for those
families if you look at what the
household support fund does one of the
ideas I'm looking at is the families
through no fault of their own but they
have someone in the the family or
themselves being unwell and need higher
energy we should be able to look at ways
of a GP being able to refer them to the
household support fund to be able to get
that additional help so we leave no
stone unturned I'm looking at every
option to be ready for the fifth
September for additional support my
message to your viewers whether they are
small businesses or families who are
really struggling who are really worried
as you say is that we'll be ready for
more support as the new prime minister
comes in you talk about you criticize
the labor plan for not being targeted
enough your Flagship policy but Liz
trusses Flagship policy is tax cuts that
is only goes to wealthier households it
does nothing for pensioners those on low
incomes and benefits yours is the
untargeted policy well Liza said a
couple of things but one that she will
have a moratorium on the energy levees
which will help with energy costs she
will also reverse the National Insurance
increase which again will help those
families that really need a help but
what she's also said Simon is she won't
be writing a budget on the leadership
campaign she'll do it once she walks
into number 10 my task my responsibility
is to give her the options to be able to
make that decision of how she targets
the help for those families that we know
are going to need it as we get through
winter and as we know that Putin will
continue to use energy as a tool to get
back at us for the help we're putting
into Ukraine we must remain United in
the face of this threat on our continent
it is not right I think that we begin to
sort of divide and turn it into a
domestic issue that's my focus is to
make those options available and then
share them with the nation there are no
easy answers Simon but my job is to make
sure we're ready I've got a great team
when I had the vaccine portfolio I had
Emily Lawson who was phenomenal I now
have Phil Duffy who's working night and
day with the team in treasury to make
those options available for the king
coming prime minister to make those
decisions you say you don't want to have
a divided country tree your parties
split right down the middle there's a
very unseemly spat going on between
these two people will say at a time of
national emergency the government has
gone missing I don't agree with that nor
do I recognize it the moment I walked
into the treasury on the 5th of July I
gathered my top leadership team I just
spoke to you about the equivalent of
Emily Lawson in uh treasury Phil Duffy
who's literally working night and day
making sure those options are on the
table for the incoming prime minister
but also the team that's operationally
delivering today that 37 billion is
equally important if I don't get that
400 pounds out the door in the next
couple of months to reduce those energy
bills in GB but also the equivalent in
Northern Ireland then I would have
failed those people if I don't make sure
that if you are a pensioner to get that
additional 300 pounds in the next few
months I would have failed if I don't
make sure you get 150 pounds if you are
disabled I would have failed so we are
working night and day to make sure we
get this done and how have all the
options for the incoming prime minister
for more help for both households that
are really struggling and for small
businesses and do you think that just a
quick one do you believe that Liz trust
does that British workers need a bit
more graft they're not working hard
enough well list was talking about is
you know can we improve productivity in
the United Kingdom you know because you
you follow these things very closely is
every potential point of productivity
Improvement means the economy improves
we can we pay for more nurses and
doctors and teachers as we see in This
brilliant school with the holiday
activities program that they're running
here and all the other services that we
need and of course have that safety net
for those people who need it most that's
what Liz is all about